just open up the drain the tuna into a
sieve just like you flayed that then
press it too hard otherwise you'll dry
out the tuna now these are water
chestnuts just slice it nice and thin
you can buy them anywhere any
supermarket chestnuts and fresh ginger
give her that rough skin on the outside
by grating the ginger you get to get all
that very nice so it juice in take your
spring onions and just slice on an angle
I like the texture of the water chestnut
with a spring onion will touch your
fresh coriander lovely next remove the
seeds from a chili to reduce its heat
without losing any flavor and finely
chopped chilies and kaffir lime leaves
roll them up nice and tight run your
knife down the center once and just chop
that makes the fish cake nice and
fragrant touch of salt touch of pepper
fish sauce just lightly seasoned the
tuna to bind all those wonderful
ingredients 2 whole eggs and give that a
nice little whisk and then add your eggs
key hands in there
start mixing
get the mixture roll it Amanda hand with
the palm pattern down nicely to cook add
a little ground nut oil to a hot pan at
the face of a clock I'm gonna go from 12
all the way around first one in these
fish cakes only take a few minutes to
cook so keeping track of the order they
go in the pan means you know which one
to turn first
could have had a nice gentle little
shake make sure that nothing's sticking
to the bottom spatula two fingers on top
turn them over
beautiful that crackling noise is
something you always want because the
tune is already cooked so we just
lightly fry them to get a nice crisp out
size and gently tear them out smell
incredible let them sit there I'm gonna
make a really nice delicious simple
dipping sauce start off little pinch of
sugar fish sauce two tablespoons that
gives you the saltiness 1 tablespoon of
rice wine vinegar and some fresh lime
juice squeeze your fresh coriander lots
of coriander and then give that lot mix
and then you have the most amazing spicy
tuna fish cakes who would have thought
something as delicious that can come out
of a can I sleep will supper in minutes
that's so mouth-watering the easy and
delicious you guaranteed to cook it
again and again and when you toss
something really important you get all
the ingredients to the end of the pan
push down and pull back next we'll
spinach in olive oil and chopped finely
then add to the chickpea mixture